today I wanted to tell you about
something that's slightly different
part of my research group is moving lab
moving lab is a bit like moving house
except we're just moving from one room
in the building to another
but unlike living in a house when you
set up a lab you don't move things
around quite as much as you do in your
house so when you start taking things in
bits they may have been in the same
place for years and my group has been in
the lab for at least 12 years and
therefore when we start taking things to
bits we discover all sorts of things
that we'd forgotten about
even I found notebooks from students
that I've forgotten their name their
chemicals that we found that are really
quite old one of my students got really
excited this bottles older than me she
said and then we rediscover things which
remind me of experiments really
successful experiments ones that didn't
work
so it's quite sad in a nostalgic way the
lab we were in wasn't very good in some
ways it had a public corridor going
through the middle so we could never
lock it
we were always shouting at people
because they were coming through without
safety glasses so the new lab is going
to be much better nice and clean with
lockable doors and a communicating door
to the rest of my group so it's going to
be very positive but moving everything
is a big hassle it's not often when you
see videos about research groups that
you see the housekeeping you see how
people have to move rooms and so on so I
wanted you to share this moment with us
so you can see new exciting experiments
are going to take place but you want to
see the anguish beforehand
both the labs the old one and new one
are on the first floor of our building
which is called the B floor the ground
floor is a and the top floor C so we're
going from lab B 11 to be 21 so it's not
very far in distance it's probably 50
meters but for all the hassle of undoing
it we could be moving to another town it
wouldn't make much difference except we
don't need to Lori
I think it's always slightly sad and I'm
a sort of person that gets quite
attached to places but on the other hand
I realize for some time that this is not
the ideal place for my colleagues to
work so I think I'm quite positive about
this particular move always in
university labs there's a shortage of
space so you have to try and make
everything as compact as possible so
some of our equipment sadly will have to
go away but if you haven't used an
instrument for 10 years or so there
really isn't much point in keeping it
because you may not get it to start
again and if you do it's not nearly as
good as a modern one so it's probably
better to try and replace it with
something that's up-to-date so you get
better results
disposing of chemicals is something that
one has take very seriously
they obviously cannot go down the drains
and so on so the chemicals are disposed
of by a professional commercial disposal
company what we have to do is to label
them say what they are so people know
how to dispose of them usually we try
and minimize the stop of chemicals we
have because it's expensive getting rid
of them but in this case quite a lot of
things have accumulated from different
projects and so we're having a big
clear-out sometimes you'll find there's
a colleague down the corridor who'd
really like to have the chemical for
their experiments and then we just give
them away
you